GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER): I'm
in the hills outside Wahaka,
and my guides Omar and Pepe
are introducing me to one
of their favorite snacks.
OK.
GORDON RAMSAY
(VOICEOVER): I can't
say I share their enthusiasm.
It's very pasty.
It's very mealy.
It's--
Did it taste
like butter to you?
Butter?
No it tasted like sawdust,
gone warm, creamed up and--
Pepe.
[speaking spanish]
[beep]
Wow, they're really good!
Um, not for me.
I feel kind of bad that
you didn't to like them,
and I'm going to give it a
second try if you're up for it.
Something also very very
unique and interesting.
Let's go.
It can't be difficult on
the back of that liquid worm.
Everyone will compete
on Gabriela's manner.
Even though they're
not my cup of tea,
I gotta think of a way
of using those worms.
OMAR: For sure it's
going to be sweeter.
Sweeter?
Unique also.
What are we looking for?
We're looking for honey ants.
GORDON RAMSAY: Honey ants?
Yes.
Here?
Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY (VOICEOVER): Omar
tells me that these arms come
out at night and collect
nectar from the plants
and trees around them to
produce their own kind of honey.
That's the food for
the rest of the colony.
But how do you get
the honey from them?
Oh, you just put
it in your mouth
and as he's put in your
mouth they're going to pop.
GORDON RAMSAY: Bloody hell.
OMAR: The cool thing is
that the ant doesn't die,
so you just pop it,
drink the honey,
and then you just put the
ant back into the hole.
GORDON RAMSAY: Really?
OMAR: Yeah.
Oh there's some ants.
That's a good sign.
OK.
OMAR: Go for it.
Just lay down on the floor.
Gordon.
Oh my god, look
how many we found.
[speaking spanish]
GORDON RAMSAY: That's all honey?
OMAR: Yeah.
GORDON RAMSAY: It
looks like a ball.
OMAR: Yeah, it's their belly.
GORDON RAMSAY: Really?
OMAR: Yes.
And there are more
hanging down here.
[speaking spanish]
GORDON RAMSAY:
There's one there.
OMAR: In the hole at the top.
Oh my god they're all there.
There's a hole full of sacks.
How beautiful are they?
OMAR: Wow.
Wow that's plenty.
GORDON RAMSAY: 1 2 4 5.
They're all
different sizes too.
GORDON RAMSAY:
They're beautiful.
Why aren't they biting?
OMAR: Because they're
Wahakans, their friendly.
GORDON RAMSAY: The actual
sack is connected to the body.
And they're a little
balloons, aren't they?
OMAR: They look like amber, no?
So just bite the belly.
You just literally
suck on it's sack?
OMAR: Yeah.
[beep]
That's [beep] delicious.
OMAR: Yes.
It tastes like sort of, sweet
honey, strong cider, vinegar.
Before my main course,
this one's my appetizer.
[interposing voices]
OMAR: Oh.
Just go for it.
GORDON RAMSAY: It's
pretty unique isn't it?
OMAR: Yes.
And he' still alive.
It's sweet.
So how come it's so sweet?
Because of what
they collect at night.
All of the flowers
and the nectar
from the different
plants around them.
GORDON RAMSAY: And would you
cook with them, or just--
OMAR: I think it would
be really hard for you
to collect a lot of them.
GORDON RAMSAY: Yeah.
The ants were delicious,
but I can't transport them.
Because you suck that
belly off the ant.
That's a little treasure.
A little nugget of
magic that Wahaka
has as a secret ingredient
that I can't take.